hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
we are going to watch today from his II
how Deadpool too should have ended who's
e I love Deadpool - he loves Deadpool -
electric Boogaloo before we do that
patron of the day shoutout for a man
named totally jumbled see over at our
patreon we do full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a music video
coverage every once in a while we give a
patron the day shout-out and today is TJ
TJ we just did a Google hangout with
this guy lovely gentleman slightly
perverted but whatever perverts have had
it rough in the past couple years so
we're gonna give him a little break I
wanna say TJ it was nice getting to know
your hot-ass wife towards the end of the
conversation she actually landed on the
Google hangout with us and we got to
talk with her I'm telling you man I
prefer talking to her way more than
talking to you that pervert that you are
she brings out that side of me when I'm
talking to her so if you could put her
on the call next time we talk that would
be great you could just stand in the
background totally okay with that
just hold your baby think about what
you've done think about what her your
purview sick pervert look what you're
turning me into yeah look what you're
doing in my man here lady writing
[Music]
[Music]
oh damn oh Vanessa
he looks pretty sounds like a regular
ball guy they're actually the music kind
of gave it away and I'm putting together
team of people with special abilities
[Music]
why don't you stop the ones responsible
[Music]
I am from the future and I'm here to
tell you that your methods caused the
death of millions and I'm going to kill
we're gonna trust you Danny Boy
[Music]
it's battery one more idea
[Music]
whoa come with me my name is and that's
how I saved Russell from cables well
because they're mean to you and that's
important except that we still murder
[Music]
down like the grooviest soundtrack this
is how the credits should have ended
[Music]
welcome to the big leagues kid
[Music]
why is it this working who are you oh I
see what's happening I can't shoot
myself because if I did that I couldn't
actually go on to become this Deadpool
well once you go back and shoot myself
silly paradox contacted me at this hour
Cope's well looks like I've got a few
more timelines to do if I wasn't wearing
a mask you could see that this puts a
smile on my face
[Music]
highly well it was either that or don't
want a quest for revenge killing the
entire Marvel Universe which although it
would have been really fun would have
taken way too long to animate don't
worry
I'll just Wilson into being I needed
some more resources so I just made them
you should consider that an option it
was my time my time you can sit and
watch the Sun Rise any time you want
Thanos don't have to kill half the
universe to do it yes I do No so anyway
no I got all the thanks I need right
here I think I'll call her Betty White
well I think I'll be on my way you who
the avada kedavra zai could dish out
with that device yeah me and this golden
girl aren't ever going to part I'm
afraid our wee girl she says no you move
what's that hmm Betty we can't say that
here won't get demonetized I did not sit
in that chair for 10 years for nothing I
will have what is rightfully mine I like
that they really make this Deadpool my
own again he knows he was there like the
timeline they have Deadpool play in here
is within the hizzy Infinity Ward yeah
not exactly the movie timeline of
infinity war but what happened in the
how it should have ended infinity war
storyline let's have him cross over into
that territory I really a make fun of
that yeah little things like that
keeping these stories going especially
across these videos especially for one
that's written by the fans are gonna
treat this Deadpool as if this is the
universe of his II for the fans they
could have just done direct reference to
the infinity war movie but I was like oh
yeah that's how it goes down and you
know it Avengers infinity or [ __ ] event
it comes on it sticks to the meta
references of being aware that it's in
the hizzy format you know even makes a D
monetization jus yeah that was a funny
like double fourth wall breaks not only
is that Deadpool it's also the channel
it's okay the wall there because they're
not as much you know to acknowledge
those kinds of things and just the
attention to detail in this to Danny
Trejo in the background like machetes
Jimmy yeah I was having a hard time
paying attention to what they were
saying in that scene because I was
noticing like oh there's been him in the
background in the background
Rambow in the background and then even
this is like these tacos don't text yeah
Dexter like that kind of thing
that's a terrible day true I just did a
cliche Mexican impersonation I'm a [ __ ]
day man I'm Danny Trejo si hands down
the buffest I've seen their Batman yeah
I was like that's actually an imposing
looking Batman you have again Shawn line
in like a five o'clock shadow I think
they were going for even though it was
the dam and the hizzy version I think
they were going for more the Ben Affleck
look the bit about how Deadpool doesn't
kill Ryan Reynolds it's like we see an
honest trailer for a comedy it's harder
to make fun of a comedy yeah that's
actually funny and like this bit is
really funny and I'm sure the fans would
have wanted them to make fun of this
famous and credit scene the post credits
me whatever watch them like well I
really do prefer the one from the movie
that was a yeah I mean like they make a
good point here that yeah I could kill
Ryan Reynolds and messes up the whole
timeline but I'm like that whatever but
there's still a fictional movie and
Austin Civ Lee Deadpool is not Ryan
Reynolds yeah yeah the fantasy I think
still holds up but I do think it's a
funny thing to make no dough it's it's
harder to make this bit funnier than
that bit exactly it's like you're never
yeah I have that punch that it was the
first time we all watch Deadpool shoot
himself yeah with the Fox and Disney
merger officially happening you know it
makes me wonder when I'm watching this
because you know how Deadpool too does
that thing where he goes meets Ryan
Reynolds kills him and then even kills
old Deadpool from origins if they let
Deadpool remain Deadpool are they gonna
do something where they allow him to do
any bits like that where he goes back to
an older Marvel movie you know I'm
wonder if they'll let him like that even
if it's just a bit but nothing that
actually affects the timeline but if
it's just a funny thing they could do
Marvel has a sense of humor so I'm
wondering they would allow Deadpool to
do that I want that to happen yeah I
feel like it would probably just be
contained to Deadpool and I don't think
the rest of the MCU will acknowledge
those things at all yeah I could see it
happening within the realm of a demo
they made some good points in terms of
storyline of why didn't they just kill
the bad teacher or whatever that ball
dude is or go back try changing him so
that way he doesn't affect Russell down
the road that is something that kind of
did pop into my mind when I was watching
the movie yeah is why not start with the
source that caused him to be
come this way I might save a whole lot
of other kids in the process too you
know and if the Deadpool movies were
more tied in story purpose wise to x-men
this storyline of him putting him with
the Xavier school of gifted mutants
whatever who would have been perfect
actually what a fit having like colossus
and negasonic teenage warhead and
there's cool and everything but they're
not really tied to the x-men movies
specifically like the Deadpool movie
zone effect that way the x-men movies
play out but if they did having Russell
be a part of the x-men team like
bringing into the school would have made
sense for the ending yeah what a man
that would have been kind of a cool
thing to see carry across future x-men
movies - yeah given that pole character
just worked his way into the house yeah
and part of the ensemble and I did
appreciate the approach to that how it
should have ended bit doing the whole
Back to the Future thing with the music
and like well the name front of the
Terminator timeline thing and they make
it home in the Back to the Future thing
yeah that was great
so funny ass [ __ ] man I think we've ever
seen one video from them we're like
half-assed this one dude yeah yeah yeah
I mean I've seen one to be funnier than
others but they always come up with
something clever they're always very
clever man you guys are hard-working
[ __ ] and I'm really happy you
guys do your job you really ramped up
the tunes in this one oh yeah you did
you guys are great at that anyway guys
subscribe to how it should have been and
if you haven't done so already you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about talk to you guys
soon